hey stena files welcome back to another
exciting edition of instant trailer
review i'm jay s and i'm david and today
we're looking at a vengers age of Ultron
yes Avengers 2 we have been waiting
since what 2012 got a long time for the
sequel we got the trailer now a lot of
people at comic-con got to see a trailer
but we didn't get to see it
unfortunately I finally seeing something
we read a lot about the stuff at
comic-con this sounds very similar I'm
this seems a lot longer yeah what they
saw comic-con so let's dive in so i
should say first and foremost that we
should not be doing this until next
tuesday was originally apparently a
hydra hacked marvel and took the trailer
out because it was supposed to come out
with agents of shield next week and then
it leaked all over the internet
yesterday but then Marvel put it up with
a really funny twitter post this a damn
it Hydra yeah it's really funny all
right so we're gonna see we see some
city we don't know what this is we've
been trying to figure out other skylines
and you don't know if it's Seattle
because it looks like there's a space
needle but it looks so specific yeah we
don't know could be somewhere please
comment below we'd like to know what
city that is and just like the first
Avengers explosions people panicking in
23 everywhere now this is we think this
is Ultron for sure now the plot of the
movie so far as we know is that Tony
Stark tries to jumpstart a dormant
peacekeeping program things go wrong and
it's up to the Avengers to stop the evil
Ultron now I think Ultron is originally
created by Hank Pym ant-man in the
comics but I think in this version it's
gonna be Tony Stark who creates sort of
a robot artificial intelligence
peacekeeping robot and he goes a little
evil and I think that's what this is
going to be about so it's they've been
keeping it a little bit secret but
Ultron I think is made by Tony Stark
right that's interesting that this is
coming out before ant-man yeah so they
couldn't have even used that to build at
Ultron but yeah we'll see um so first
and foremost again it's starting with
all this destruction of starting at a
very dark place yeah we're starting very
brooding and I love this shot here
Captain America just looks like I've
been fighting all day and I'm tired and
we looked at the license plates and
we're pretty sure that South Korea just
because we know that Avengers 2 shot in
South Korea those license plates seem to
be appropriate for that and there's
Hawkeye the really cool lens flare shot
and they're clever i will get some more
screen time yeah what's so super Hawkeye
yeah Thor escape um now here we have all
the Avengers together on was probably a
shield ship then bruce banner looks like
he's shivering he's really cold I guess
maybe fell into some ice water but he's
just taking a quick shower yeah it's
like there he is he's like really cold
yeah and I've read in interviews that
the Hulk Bruce banners gonna have a lot
more screen time in this movie he's
gonna have a lot more about his story oh
come now we only really saw the solo
movie The Incredible Hulk with Edward
Norton greatly movie by the way yeah we
both really liked that one it's
unfortunate Edward Norton couldn't
really do the avengers movie but now
we're finally gonna see more hulk and
like are still waiting for that solo
hulk movie mark ruffalo now here we have
what clue is like such a like as
marionette would be yeah sort of a
marionette style Iron Man suit that's
been burned up we don't know why that's
a perfect description let me the way
it's holding itself in a gang and that's
gonna come into play later when we talk
about the trailer song choice so yeah I
definitely think this is probably Starks
apartment or something because we say
have like weights it's very stylish and
levering all the Avengers are very
shocked to see an Iron Man suit you know
a tony stark himself sort of walking on
its own like a puppet with strings now
if you actually go back and look um you
can see an Avengers logo mmm so there
now finally adopting the adventure says
like a brand name from just that's great
oh yeah moment so that there is some
serious stuff going down and they got
this is this marble logo it's like we
need of steel and guest took an iron
plate and just cut it out there they've
gone flat okay now we don't we don't
really know what this is I assume it's
the Alps it looks very German to me
we're Swiss or something Bangladesh is
also on the filming location yes they
also filmed I believe in Italy and
England and Johannes Berg South Africa
um now if you remember the end of winter
soldier we sort of meat Baron von
Strucker and the Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch and I think it's this location I
think it's somewhere in Eastern Europe
locus because Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch our European for Eastern European
yeah and now this Quicksilver and this
movie is different
the days of future past Quicksilver yeah
a lot of people don't know this but Fox
has the rights to x-men and mutants and
Disney has the rights to these
characters and they sort of made a
decision legally that they can use
Quicksilver in the same powers they
can't mention magneto they can't mention
mutants so these quicksilver's called
which are not mutants in this version
right it was funny actually had a comic
con elizabeth Olsen almost said the word
mutant and everyone like in that whole
room was just like oh but yeah so
different these are different characters
even though they're the same yeah but
i'm pretty sure they're gonna the same
powers uh Scarlet Witch was not in the
x-men movies but we saw you know
Quicksilver had super speed and that one
I think he's gonna have it in this one
too we can see I'm running now these
police I assume this is America because
it's and it looks like i'm an american
place and the right outside walk tall is
that like some made-up comic stores yeah
so if you know what walk tall is comment
below because i haven't i've never heard
of it yeah again so there are the
destruction they took us some b-roll
from the movie fury and inserted it in
here great movie why not now if you look
actually in this shot you look in the
background you can see I think a tank
yeah I think I think this is why Bruce
Banner shivering as he went into the
cult that would make a lot of sense now
that's black widow and that's a really
cool shot like Don Draper okay this is
gonna come back into play a little bit
later because what it what room is she
in this is basically like a dance space
is it not I mean that's an office I
don't look at that skirt and cooper's
listen i'm from admin they're just there
these are so glad these are mirrors on
both sides i'm gonna come by chance to
dance dude you know I say it's an
advertising company okay either way now
this is I don't there's some other movie
that does this shot right a lot of
movies I'm that every single student
film does this okay yeah yeah so put the
camera than mice will now who's being
operated on here we don't know okay
moving on and that's definitely Ultron
and that we don't really know where they
are but that's got to be quick silver
and that's gotta be Scarlet Witch yeah
um now actually another thing about this
movie is that Paul Bettany is gonna be
in it playing vision yeah now Paul
Bettany does the voice Jarvis who's the
sort of in the comics Jarvis is like a
British Butler and they updated
modernized it for the movies to be sort
of a century a artificial intelligence
robot now finally we're staying like a
physical form of that and I think that's
really cool but we don't see it in this
trailer it
all yeah we don't see vision we've seen
concept art and we've seen them I think
a picture of them and in the comics
Scarlet Witch I think it's married to
vision so i don't know if they're gonna
play a romance angle and he's along that
iron man is always talking to inside of
his suits yeah I'm it's Jarvis yeah also
in Godzilla they're married and they're
kissing each other so that's gonna be
weird to see the brother and sister now
and this I'm sure we're gonna get some
super coats of that that's gonna be some
weird YouTube parodies of incest for
sure now this is definitely Ultron but
kind of like a like a different version
that we're gonna see at the end here but
as you can tell there's a lot of Ultron
robots yeah they're building up an army
every shot of the Avengers in this movie
they all look like astonished and like
uh uh an incredibly dirty yeah yeah so
jess how do you think this trailer is
different than the first Avengers movie
well first and foremost like we said it
is darker like from the get-go and I
think the very first teaser for Avengers
was that way as well but it definitely
showed the lightheartedness you know the
fact yeah it had a very Disney family
feeling this one's darker right um
there's also some sepia tone in this one
remember what were the colors like for
the images right yeah the first
offenders has sort of a blue and purple
and fun and like this one's dark and
sepia and red rum and now Joss Whedon
has said in interviews that this movie's
more inspired by Empire Strikes Back and
godfather part two and he said it's
gonna be more painful and more personal
so I'm looking forward to that yeah
that's always a good sign if you look at
Donna the plan of the Apes that was also
largely inspired by God fathers who and
it went some very handy place I story
okay so Stark they're ours yeah I'm good
mabini and then Samuel Jackson he's also
now I've read in interviews that he's
gonna have a smaller role in this movie
but Nick Fury knows how to dress look at
him he is cool um and by this toilet
which we don't have the audio going but
by this point the the actual song has
started playing I believe oh yeah so the
music that's playing is um I got no
strings I think by Pinocchio yeah it's
from Pinocchio movie now remember Disney
owns both Pinocchio and Avengers so
they're allowed to use that so they're
digging into the archive do you think
Pinocchio is gonna make an appearance in
this that would be terrible maybe a bad
idea but basically Ultron is Pinocchio
in the sense that like a puppet coming
to life yeah and causing some mischief
okay now Ultron is voiced by NBC
James Spader or any our site this is the
blacklist James Spader if you watch the
NBC does not own James Spader lucky easy
on the show yeah he's on the show the
blacklist which is really popular now
what do you think of James Spader for
this oh it's great James Spader is such
a fun presence to have on screen and
even though we're just gonna be seeing
his for hearing his voice and I guess
his motion capture as well yeah he did
the motion capture but reportedly when
he showed up for the first day he gave
his performance and the entire cast and
crew just like stood up and applauded
him like they were blown away that's why
we look hold it and who this is the
Hulkbuster awesome now we don't really
see who's inside it looks like it could
be iron man's head but from what we kind
of figured out is that it's possible the
Iron Man suits become controlled by
Ultron yeah um doesn't this remind you
of the guy in the waiting room and
beetlejuice but the tiny lad okay so I
think so we we assume they'll start
created this Hulk Buster outfit to fight
the Hulk in case the Hulk ever becomes
crazy and they need to take him down
yeah um which would make sense and in
the comics I think that's the same thing
we have like widow on a motorcycle but
in their silver / beating Charlotte
which here's a random show okay Andy
Serkis usually does motion capture area
is playing a human this is his real face
a lot of people have never seen that
before and that beard I mean do we know
who he's playing in this film I couldn't
find anything here's thou'rt like just
taking a bath now okay la sequence is
very random right you know what I think
I think this is black widows like a
flashback to her past that would be
that's why she's going to that dance
studio later on in this different room I
know but still she sees any studio and
she's like remembering her days as a
ballerina it's just it's very odd in a
trailer to go from an action action to
some ballerinas this is already a meme
online like I've seen this pop up in my
den I think so i think that's
Quicksilver playing piano but i can't
tell or it looks like it could be
Captain America's hair I don't know yeah
who knows okay work some more fury busy
role yeah this scene excites me I hope
we get to see
they also backed the Hulkbuster now if
you remember Hulk spot Thor and the
first movie and then the trailer of the
first movie made a lot of emphasis on
that sort of flight between Captain
America and Iron Man and Thor in the
forest so I think they're sort of doing
that again about they're not always
getting a law so are you guessing that
Tony Stark and the whole system I think
it's Ultron controlling Hulk Oh hug
Buster okay all right more car flipping
yeah okay so I mean now it's just
basically a sizzle reel of the action at
this point which is not a bad thing at
all it's showing us a lot so jess do you
think we're gonna see any of the
guardians of the galaxy anisty think
roots will show up that would be too
cool what I'm equal I would say no I
don't think we're gonna see that this
earlier but if i believe around may 2015
when this movie comes out daredevil
comes out on netflix so hopefully
there's some tie-in with that i really
hope some i also wonder how agents of
shield will tie in was the greatest
thing about marvel is the shared
universe for sure it's very cool and he
makes reference to the no string yeah me
you know which is just chillin and I
love the look of this Ultron robot he's
so menacing um um so is this trailer
gave me the chills first time I saw it
and that the first time I saw was on the
phone last night actually because I
thought it was leaked and then we found
out that Marvel actually put it out
themselves i was like wow so yeah a
great first look at age of Ultron what
do you think yeah i think it's great i
think it's interesting they don't
introduce the characters because you
just don't need to like it's interesting
most trailers always introduce
characters a little more there's not
much exposition but it's it's just
mysterious enough to be interesting
believe it or not this is the eleventh
film and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so and that's been in blood like eight
years since yeah so yeah we we have been
well introduced to this cast already
it's time to just jump in for the latest
adventure yeah so I'm excited from a
2015 and all the little with the next 30
if Marvel movies they already have the
the Captain America 3 Civil War stuff
being planned out and that's awesome so
I guess that's it this was a great
trailer they're full of images let us
know what you spotted in the comments
below we'd love to see what you guys
have investigated here um but for movie
clips send Fandango I'm j/s and I'm
David thanks for watching
Oh